Hello, Berlin?
How is everyone?
It's a pleasure to be here on the stage.
I've been coming to JSConf for years and so
privileged, and it's a pleasure to be back
on the stage and give back to the community.
Sad that I'm not here with my family because
coming back to JSConf every time feels like
coming back to see my family, and I think
that's because of the amazing community we
have built here, and the organisers built.
A massive round of applause for the organisers
for allows us all to be here to do this.
[Applause].
My name is Patrick Hamann.
I work for the Edge Cloud provider Fastly
where we specialise in real time content delivery
for the world's leading brands.
I there get a lot of time to sit, think about,
and research how we can make our customers'
websites load as fast as possible, and that's
what I'm here to talk to you about today.
Why am I actually here and what does the clickbait-y
Buzzfeed headline of to push or not to push
mean?
I'm not going to quote Hamlet to you now.
The reason I'm here is because of this.
I hear this all the tile.
I've sat on stages and said exactly this that
HTTP/2 is going to solve this problem, literally
everyone.
The problem is that it's not.
Resource diabetic loading in the browser is
very, very hard.
After this talk, hopefully, you will have
a better understanding of why it's hard and
the techniques we have today to overcome the
problems it produces.
Why is it hard?
Performance is coupled to latency.
Connection s costs are high.
TCP's congestion control algorithm is there
for very good reasons but penalises us at
the beginning after connection when it's most
important.
Our critical resources can be hidden to the
browsers.
Browsers are extremely powerful things and
have speculative parses but they simply are
not magic enough to know the resources that
you as an application developer want to load.
Because of that, bandwidth is often under
utilised, leaving idle connections open where
we could be sending resources but we can't
do that yet because of the way that browsers
and servers interact with each other.
Finally, once we do get it down script, it
is extremely to expensive to parse and execute
and we waste idle time on the network again
because of that.
How can we load our resources mostly?
What patterns and techniques can we use today
and what is coming up in the future to enable
us to do in the most efficient and speedy
way?
Think about the product or website that you're
designing today.
If you are only allowed to send three resources
down the wire, would what they be?
Is it your fonts?
The lazy-loaded related comments on the bottom
of this ft.com home page or adverts?
I don't think so.
What did the user come here for?
Bench wars from Calibre, who is sitting with
us here today, when we talk about loading,
we talk about a critical request path, and
he defines a critical request as one that
contains an asset that is essential to the
content to the user's view port.
What are your critical resources.
I want you really to take this away from my
talk as I want you to think about what are
the two or three things you need to send down
as soon as possible so that browser can get
on with rendering and creating a good user
experience for your users.
A critical CSS for your initial route?
Font or hero images.
One we don't discuss enough is the application
bootstrap data.
A lot of client-side rendered applications
probably make a JSON request that is hidden
to the browser.
It is known as a hidden sub resource and the
browser doesn't know about it upfront.
We need to be able to tell the browser what
the resource is specifically to our need,
and to create the delightful user experiences.
Once you've determined what your critical
requests are, you need to think about how
they contribute to the user's experience.
After all, performance is a user experience
problem.
What resources do you need to get a first
meaningful paint?
What resources do you have to deliver so that
users can start interacting with your website
as fast as possible.
It's this section here we will focus on today,
this initial loading experience, and how we
can tell the browser, make, allow the browser
to make informed decisions about what it load
so we can have delightful users' experience.
So I summarise a good loading strategy as
one that prioritises above the file rendering,
prioritising interactivity.
It is easy to use because some we look at
today aren't necessarily, and innovate importantly,
measurable.
The first solution to overcoming a performance
problem is to measure your current performance,
if then optimise for it.
So the first technique that we are doing,
now that we've identified what we should be
loading, let's see how we can do this efficiently.
The first I'm going to discuss is the preload
API.
What if we could tell the browser ahead of
time what the critical resources are required
for this?
The problem is earlier on we identified fonts,
and application bootstrap data, as being critical
resources.
However, they're hidden from the browser.
Why is this?
First, you make a get request for the home
page been we wait for the response of that.
HTML can be parsed I can be mentally so, as
the bytes come down the wire, the browser
can start constructing the DOM without waiting
for the HTML file to be delivered.
They have speculative parses that goes ahead
while it's constructing the DOM, finds the
file sheets and script tags references in
the page and initiates fetches for them ahead
of time.
But with CSS, unfortunately, it is render-blocking
and can't be parsed incrementally.
We have to wait for all the bytes to come
down first because if we didn't, there would
be lots of painting flashing on the screen
because of the way the cascade works.
Eventually, it is only until this point that
the CSS object it model and the document object
model combine to form the render tree.
It is only at this point when we have the
render tree and we've done the networking
first which is when the browser will dispatch
the font request.
Your CSS may reference five or six font files
but only two are being used for the initial
load.
This is why fonts are known as criticals hidden
sub resources.
The browser can't know about them up front.
The idea of preload is what if we could provide
a declarative fetch primitive that initiates
an early fetch, decoupling that logic, saying
to the browser, "I know you're going to find
the font later on, and I know you need it,
or for your JavaScript application, I know
you're going to make a request about a JSON
file to the user, you won't find it later
in the process," I know about it, perform
the networking for it now.
That's why it is extremely powerful.
Here, we have three new primitives, one via
HTML, and one by JavaScript, by our HTTP link
headers.
We also have had module preload specification
for those shipping the native browsers already.
Fonts have to be requested as non-origin,
so this is really powerful.
By adding three HTTP headers, we can tell
the browser upfront about our critical resources.
So if we were to look at the network waterfall
for featherweight dominate, for instance,
before applying this, you will see that the
font files are really low priority here, and
because they haven't been discovered until
the CSS file has been parsed, but just by
adding the preload headers, we can instantly
prioritise and initiate those fetches early,
and so the browser can get on with it.
Customers saw they had 50 per cent, 1.2 seconds,
improvement by adding preload headers for
their font files and hidden sub roars.
I've never known a single technique that's
one line of code that can have a two-second
average improvement on the user experience
of loading up a page.
The question that I want to ask, and propose
to you, is: is indicating resource hints via
the HTML like this, in fact, too late in the
connection flow, too late in the loading experience
of the page?
And that is what HTTP/2 server push comes
in, or was specifically designed to solve.
Let's look at how it can help us.
First, let's look at the traditional request
flow that you to make when you're loading
a page.
You perform a get request to your server.
The server has server think time and perform
a database action, or render some template.
All of the time this is thinking, and, then
eventually, it will respond with your index.html.
Then the browser stars parsing it.
This makes me sad because we've left the connection
open for so long whilst the browser, the server
was doing that think time.
At Fastly, we see an average server think
time of 200 to 400 milliseconds wasted on
the wire here, and round-trip can be 800 to
1,000 milliseconds on a good 3G connection.
What if the server could predict the next
thing the client is going to request is that
main CSS file and flush the bytes for it down
as soon as it receives that get request.
How soon can I use push?
If you have an HTTP/2 server enabled today,
Node natively supports it, we've converged
using our link preload header to use as the
semantic of "I want to push this resource,"
so if your server is HTTP/2 enabled, it will
read these and initiate pushes for you.
Really super quick win.
If you don't want to push and you still want
the semantics of preload, you can add the
no-push attribute there, and at Fastly, we
realise that you might only want to push and
not have a race between push and preload,
and we allow you to say that and will strip
the header on the way out.
What benefit does this actually give us?
If we look to our common waterfall for loading
a page, we've got the index file, then we
look for the CSS, we find that, and then perform
the networking for the JavaScript, and the
CSS.
By pushing the resource, we are saving one
round trip here, the light-shaded bit.
The round-trip time is the time it takes for
the client to send the request to hit the
server and back again until we start receiving
the first bytes.
Again, on a 3G connection in Europe, that
could be as about 800 milliseconds, in some
other developing areas, that could be seconds.
So it's great.
It gives us a one round-trip time saving to
improve our loading experience.
But in the here it's idle time still left
on the connection.
This makes me really, really sad.
Why is this?
Let's look again at this request flow.
As a server push is indicated via the link
header, we have to wait for the server to
do its think time in responding before we
as a server, or your proxy layer, your CDN,
if you use Apache is only until we've received
all of the HTML bytes that we initiate that
push.
That is far too late in the connection flow
because we've still got this idle connection
time.
This makes me really sad.
Wasn't this what push was designed to solve?
To summarise, push gives us a round trip saving,
I would argue the fact that, if you need,
with , you have got no that long server think
time, you should be optimising your servers
instead.
Is link header far too late in the connection
flow?
And this is where asynch push comes in.
To be able to truly utilise push, we need
to decouple the pushing behaviour from our
applications HTML response, and do it right
at the beginning of the connection flow.
So a more common architecture as I discussed
you may have a CDN or a proxy as it receives
that request it is only there and then whilst
we have that server think time, we can push
the bytes down the wire.
I forgot to mention earlier on that the way
that push works is HTTP/2 has a binary data
framing layer.
This is a magical thing that allows us no
longer just plain text on the wire, on our
TCP connection, now we have binary frames
allowing us to interleave separate data frames
for subsequent requests or multiple questions
at the same time, called multiplexing.
This is why we can have a single HTTP/2 open
and deliver hundreds of resources at the same
time.
Push works by sending a push promise frame,
as you can see here, a data frame sent to
the client saying I'm going to send you these
bytes, and here they are, go and have them.
Utilising idle connection time like this makes
me extremely happy.
Again you're wondering how you can do this.
This is using Node standard HTTP/2 standard
library.
I've got a request handler here.
I checked to see if the URL matches.
If it does, I want to initiate a push, here
is where you can flush down your critical
resources that you've identified, piping they
think them down a extreme, and then you can,
down a stream, and then you can — so let's
see the benefits that this has on our waterfall.
As you can see here, when our push example,
we had the one round-trip saving when using
the link header.
By using asynch push, we've hit the Holy Grail
that we are pushing the styles that JavaScript
required to render the screen before the HTML
is even consumed.
Now the browser has all of the information
it needs instantly to render as soon as the
HTML is finished.
That makes Patrick extremely happy!
But what about the repeat view I hear you
asking?
I definitely ask this a lot.
We have already sent the assets to the clients.
The client should have that asset in its patch.
The problem is that we've got no way of indicating
that the serve questioner and what is in its
cache.
What will happen is on the repeat view and
will be detrimental here and create tension
on the underlying network link and end up
worse than when you [sound feed distorted].
The request
never even goes out to the network, and so
we don't have to push, so we benefit from
not having to worry about the cache state.
But that's only if you have a service worker,
and a lot of us may not have.
So the server has got no knowledge of the
class state, and this is a really, really
big problem.
What is the problem?
The theory there is great: push should be
amazing.
We should be able to give the client all of
the information it needs before I've even
received the HTML but the adoption is extremely
low.
Why is that?
What is the problem?
I also want to make a poll here: who is using
H2 in production right now?
Leave your hands up if you're also using push.
So only about ten per cent of the people that
were using push, and there was only probably
only about 20 per cent of the room using H2
at all.
What is the problem?
Why is no-one adopting it?
To do that, let's take a look at the request
flow again.
Once we've sent the get requests, and we start
pushing the bytes down the wire, I lied to
you earlier on.
Even though the browser doesn't have a mechanism
for telling its cache state, it has a mechanism
to reset that stream, so you can send a reset
stream saying I don't want those bytes any
more, I've got it in my cache.
Unfortunately, we've got a race condition
here that, by the time the client has initiated
the reset stream but by the time that gets
to the server, because our critical resources
are normally small, we have flushed the bytes
down the wire already, or, if more importantly,
they left the user space, it's inside their
TCP buffer, and once something is in the kernel's
TCP space, there's no way for an application
to prevent those being flushed down the physical
listening.
We've got a race conditions here which isn't
a good thing.
The new quick protocol that was — QUIC protocol
is going to hopefully solve a lot of those
problems by moving a lot of the application
layer out of the kernel into user space and
allow us to do amazing things here.
Another common area of misconception of HTTP/2
server push is how the servers cache that
resource.
Once I pushed all the bytes down, still a
request that is initiated from your page needs
to claim that resource from the HTTP/2's push
cache.
A push cache is not connected to the HTTP
cache, it is connected to the lifetime of
that single HTTP/2 connection, so, for every
H2 connection you have to an origin, you're
going to have a dedicated push cache for that.
One of the problems is that the push cache
is the last to be requested.
As the request leaves the page, first it will
go to the memory cache attached to that document,
it's all of the resources that document has
already requested.
Then it will be looked up in the service worker
cache, then the HTTP cache, the service worker
caches are shared globally where the memory
caches are pushed, and finally, it will try
and look inside the push cache.
It's highly likely a lot of the time the push
cache will never be claimed, and therefore
therefore you've wasted sending bytes down
the wire.
The other tricky thing here to note is that
HTTP/2 connections are credentialed or non-credentialed
which is why a font file has to be served
as a non-credentialed resource.
If a CSS file was to push a font file, the
CSS file is credentialed and so actually won't
be able to claim the font file request.
So to summarise, the problem here is the push
cache is hats to be authoritative for it,
a single cache per connection.
The items can only be claimed once, so, if
you have multiple tabs open for the single
one, the push can only be sent once, and you
have to repeat that push.
The thing that I find is that the cache behaviour
is not specced as part of the implementation.
If you do consider using HTTP/2 push, I urge
you to read this blog post by Jake Archbold,
where he goes into great detail and the browser
inconsistencies, and it's tougher than we
thought it was.
A tl;dr summarisation of that, we can only
ably use it in Chrome and Firefox.
The networking stack is — Edge have done
great work.
One of the great things that Jake did in this
post was to document all the problems and
create tickets on all of the browsers bug
trackers, so my hat's off to Jake for doing
that.
Edge are improving but not yet.
Still one connection per tag.
This leaves us to UA sniff for push.
That's really, really bad, and we know what
happens when we start going down that route
of UA sniffing.
The race of adoption.
For instance as at Fastly, we only see 0.008
requests — that's 800 questions out of a
million, we do around 6 million requests a
second, that we see a push initiated.
If it was so good, everybody should be using
it, but they're not.
This lack of adoption has got so bad that
certain vendors have considered ripping push
out of the HTTP/2 specification entirely.
When should you push?
Only if you have long round-trip times or
an app shell architecture and you could use
the purple appear or if you could manage your
own cache state natively, or if you've got
a native application or an electron app.
Is that round-trip worth the complexity of
the benefits it gives us, and are there simple
solutions out there that we can use?
This is why I want to talk about what is ahead
for us in the future.
Can we just fix the HTTP push problems?
They're quite simple.
What can we do to fix that?
That is where the cached digest specification
comes in.
What if the browser, whenever it created a
new connection could send a frame called a
cache digest that contained a cuckoo filter
which is a probabilistic data structure representing
all the items the browser has for the clash
of that host name?
Then the server can be much more intelligent
about what it wants to push.
It's I'm not going to push main.css but I
will send you the new version of my JavaScript
application because you don't have the latest
version of that.
I'm excited by not just for solving push,
this opens up a lot of great opportunity for
us for instance in the JavaScript bundling
and modules world that we could choose and
be more intelligence of what we bundle and
what we send down and we have a bit more knowledge
about the client cache state.
Going back to the repeat view, if we had cache
digests for our first view we could push and
on the subsequent view, the client says I've
got that in my resource and we wouldn't have
to push it.
Cache digest specification is an experimental
in ITF at the moment.
It was proposed by my colleague, and it's
been worked on, but I think we're going to
see implementations land in browsers soon.
Fastly have got the first implementation of
the server side as that of that in that you
are open source server, but this seems too
complicated.
Like we are still having to maintain a lot
of logic to manage state between the client
and the server.
Http after all is a stateless protocol, why
it's so beautiful.
It is complicated.
This is where the 103 early-hint specification
comes in.
This is again pursued by my colleague.
Who has heard of 100 informational ranges
at all?
I hadn't at all until this came out.
New HTTP response code that allows the server
to indicate to the client the resource that
is are going to be required for the 200 response
that is coming.
It looks like this, when we perform a Get
request, we then send down an initial response
just containing headers using our friend link
preload and the browser gets to decide I've
got this and don't have that, and initiates
the fetches early during the think time.
This is what it would look like on the wire.
It is as simple as that.
This is why it's more powerful than push because
we are moving that logic and decision process
back to the browser where it belongs, so the
server can send down a 103 response saying
here are the critical resources for this page,
you decide what you want to do with it and
follow up with a 200.
Again, this has been accepted by ITF in experimental
mode.
We've got a working implementation on the
server side but the problem is at the moment,
many browser are worried about the complexity
this adds to the networking stack and worried
we will break the internet because middle
proxies don't understand the 100 range but
only served over TLS to overcome the problems.
Early hints gives us all the same benefits
as push but possession simpler and we can
leverage the browser cache now not have the
complexities of the H2 server push cache and
it's great because it allows the client to
do the decision-making.
We've got preload to do the headers, and new
specification coming out that allows us to
decorate our HTML with resources saying I
know this hero image is high priority but
this fetch request is low.
I urge you to go and check out the specification
and add to the GitHub page here.
So, in closing, I've run out of time, so I've
got to wrap up.
Eve only scratched the surface here of methodologies
but I hope I've given you techniques to use
today.
HTTP/2 doesn't solve everything but there
are a lot of things to solve this.
Resource-loading in the browser is hard but
I'm excited by the future.
Most importantly, performance is for humans.
Optimise for a good user experience, not for
the networking stack.
Measure your experience and optimise for that.
So, the checklist, if I was going to do today,
identify your critical resources, preload
any hidden sub resources, avoid push for possible
and the future is looking great.
We can use early hints when they become available.
Thank you very much.
[Applause].